Hello, and welcome to this video, Example 2, Organize the World Outliner.
In this, we are just going to use a script to manipulate and change the actors inside the world.
So here we are in the editor, and I'm going to jump to the slide 8, Example 2, Organize World Outliner.
And what we're going to be doing in this is rather than working with assets which sit within the content browser or on disk,
we're going to be working with the actors that are within this level.
Now, what I've got is I have a Python script which will automatically organize our world outliner.
Now, I'm not going to ask you to write code for this. What we're going to do is we are going to fire up the code out of the options.
So if you were to come up to tools, you'll see that we have two options here, Execute Python Script or Execute Recent Python Script.
I'm going to choose Execute Python Script. That's going to bring up a window.
You can see I have a couple of options here, but one of them is Python code.
And in this, I have a whole load of pre-written Python scripts.
Now, these are all available here for you to pick apart so you can get an idea of how different things might work.
But for this case, the one that I want to do is World Outliner Sort.
So I'm going to select that, push open and give it one second.
It's almost instantaneous here, but you might have missed it.
All the static meshes have been moved into a static mesh directory and all of my blueprints have been moved into a blueprint directory.
So really straightforward.
I could have just run it from the command line.
But let's have a quick look at the code.
So here we can see the code and it's relatively straightforward.
What we're doing is we are grabbing the editor level library because that's going to be our equivalent of our asset thing.
We're going to be able to edit stuff that's within the library. We get all actors, then we filter by class.
And you can see here that we have a mapping. So at the moment, I only have a mapping in here for static mesh and blueprints.
You can easily add extra ones into it. And all we do is loop through them and set the folder path equivalently based off of this mapping.
It's really straightforward, but it does give you an example of how you can trigger some code.
You can have pre-written sets of code and an external IDE. Bear in mind you'd need to have a stub file if you want autocomplete.
And you'll be able to just fire them off from the menu bar at the top.
And with that, it brings us to the end of this video on Example 2 Organise the World Outliner.
In the next video, we'll be jumping onto the next example.